i feel like uh
uh wrestlers are like ufc fighters like
if you go out people try to step up to
you or is everybody kind of
super cool with you you know i was
always the guy that for some reason if i
walked into a bar and got dang we was in
a lot of bars back in the day
in hotel lobbies because man after the
matches it was it was time to get it on
and i always always get this drunk
skinny [ __ ] back in the corner
looking at my arms can he come up to me
you want arm wrestle and i'm thinking
that's the thing that i heard the most i
wouldn't i wasn't one of those guys that
got into a [ __ ] pile of fights like some
of the other boys did
i was that guy that every drunk son of a
[ __ ] wanted to arm wrestling
and and i hate arm wrestling because i'm
not good at it and i don't like it and i
hate
losing and being stone cold steve austin
you don't want to get
you know your ass whipped an arm
wrestling contest on a bar in front of
everybody
so i just i'd always say no dude i said
man what are you drinking
let me buy you one of those let's just
[ __ ] shoot the [ __ ] or whatever so
i'd always defuse that and i never
accepted an arm wrestling challenge
that's great yeah it's not the world arm
wrestling federation
no i might have uh i might have told you
this when we were
when we were together but the question
that i always
got the most is dude is there any way
you'd kick me in the nuts
everybody wants to be kicked in the nuts
by stevo
yeah and for many years i thought who am
i to dash a man's dreams
[Laughter]
but back in the days before you know and
if a guy asks you to kick him in a
nutshell
and you went ahead and obliged there
wasn't going to be no lawsuit involved
you kick a [ __ ] in the balls too
hard he's going to sue you
wow they're having plenty of times when
i say okay i'll do that but first i need
you to hold up your driver's license i'm
going to make a little video on my phone
and you're going to say out loud that
this is your wish and that you consent
so i yeah i've definitely covered my
base in in that respect
a little bit yeah dude